every day is an opportunity of change I
want people to be aware of it that you
don't have to shoot for little goals but
you can shoot for big cores that it is
just as difficult to shoot for a little
goal than to shoot for a big core and to
make them recognize that they don't have
to get stuck where they are but they can
change they shouldn't be afraid of
failure that this comes naturally in
life there will be failure and there
will be successes the important thing is
that we learn from that but not to be
Frozen and to be the fear that I want
them to know that they have to create a
vision of where they want to go without
a vision there is just nowhere to go you
use it's just the way it is in life you
would just wander around without a
mission without the joy of chasing
something how much fun it is to chase
something so I want them to learn those
basic lessons that makes you just more
successful and better